is from these accounts that they will be
paying for russian gas which will be
delivered from tomorrow from first of
april of this year
if such payments are not made
we will consider this as their failure
to carry out their
commitments by buyers with all the
consequences
we don't get anything free of charge and
we're not going to engage in charity
either therefore the current contracts
will be
stopped i stress the situation in which
the financial system of the western
countries is weaponized when companies
from those countries refuse to
to honor their contracts with companies
and physical
persons when
euro accounts are frozen
it makes no sense to use those countries
currencies what we have effectively what
has happened effectively we have
delivered
our resources to european consumers in
particular gas they received it
they paid for it in euros which
then they frozen
they froze
in this connection there are grounds to
believe that
parts of the gas which delivered to
europe has been
delivered free of charge
of course this cannot continue this way
especially that since in the case of
future supplies
in the traditional scheme the new
financial receipts in euros and dollars
can also be blocked
we can expect such a
situation
especially that some politicians in the
west talk about this publicly moreover
it is in this
but
and the risks of this situation are of
course unacceptable and if we look at
the issue in
its entirety
the payment for
russian gas and russian rubles is an
important step to strengthening our
financial and economic sovereignty
we will continue
to consistently and systematically move
in this direction
in the national currencies in our
contracts and the countries that are on
our side you know that the traditional
suppliers of
of energy resources
in the world also talk about
payments in their currencies we
are serious about our reputation and we
will honor our commitments on all
contracts including gas contracts and we
will provide gas in the established
volumes and at the prices defined in the
current long-term contracts i stress
these prices are several fold lower than
the current
prices on the markets what this does
this mean russian gas is a
cheaper energy heating electricity in
european's homes